next question today is from Lopez Lopez
says won't businesses just move to other
countries if we increase taxes on them
basically the answer is no not in any
statistically significant way this is a
very common canard that's floated by the
anti-tax right in the United States and
maybe also in Europe all the way I
follow that less closely the idea here
is if you are a corporation and the
government increases your taxes you
would be incentivized to move your
operation to some other country that has
a lower tax rate there's a couple things
that we have to discuss there but let's
start with the sort of most basic I mean
American companies mostly are American
yes there are multinationals which
already are doing business all over the
world and they can more easily move
their headquarters if not all physical
presence but what you have to remember
is a lot of those companies have already
established all sorts of tax shelters
and havens so that's not going to
dramatically change if they've already
determined well we do better by having
an Irish headquarters but we still have
the American presence because we have
the United States such a major market
that is one reason why they are not
going to say we're going to relinquish
our position in the United States
altogether the other thing you have to
remember is even though you might be
able to avoid some American business
taxes if you move your operation to
another country then you risk having
added tariffs if you still want to do
business with American consumers and
corporations and that in some cases may
end up sort of zeroing out the tax
benefit but most importantly all but the
biggest businesses are simply not going
to move to other countries if you
consider all small businesses and even
most medium-sized businesses that
operate primarily in the United States
if you have a huge roofing company or a
construction company not like a local
construction company but the big real
estate companies and you basically work
in the US why are you gonna move to
another country doesn't make any sense
it's logistically significant oh it's
it's logistically significant
undertaking and you're an American
company with American custom
an all-american speaking American
English speaking employees so it's just
not practical to think that that's what
people are going to do now
we actually have some data where we can
analyze this because the same claim has
been made for a really long time about
rich people it's easier for a rich
person to move to another country or to
a lower tax state than it is for a huge
company to move from one country to
another and it turns out that
millionaires don't move very much
millionaires actually move way less than
poor people about half the rate only 2.4
percent of millionaires move in any
given year versus 4.5% of poorer
Americans and interestingly when
millionaires do decide to move they
slightly favor lower tax states slightly
many millionaires are moving to higher
tax states many millionaires move to the
states with the same level of tax and
some millionaires move to lower tax
states and for 85 percent of them the
tax rate in the state they are moving to
is not an important consideration if you
go from looking at millionaires to
looking at billionaires 84% of
billionaires live in their country of
birth period and there's no solid
evidence that tax rates are influencing
them in terms of where it is that they
want to live but here's the really
important part eighty four percent of
new billionaires live in their birth
country 16 percent of billionaires don't
live in their birth country but almost
all of them moved to that country before
they were billionaires meaning that if
the tax rate was a consideration it was
a consideration in some vague distant
way if they ever are billionaires they'd
be better off in one country versus
another rather than I'm moving now
because I want to save money on taxes so
of course when you get to the margins
you have to consider if a government
puts ridiculously high taxes on
corporations it is going to serve as
more of an incentive to move country for
that reason what we're talking about in
the United States about eliminate
loopholes and write-offs and some of
these other mechanisms that exist for
corporations to end up paying almost no
taxes or sometimes no taxes or even
getting tax credits even though they
made profit for the most part these are
changes well within the sort of
reasonable that are not going to cause
those businesses to relocate I'm sure
you can find individual instances of
anything in a country of 330 million
people but from a macroeconomic level
it's been widely widely debunked